well is with Warren versus the field was
not the only battle that unfolded during
last night's democratic debate there was
also Tulsi Gabbard versus the entire US
press corps unlike virtually everyone
else in her party Gabbard believes in
keeping America out of pointless foreign
entanglements and for that belief she
has been tarred repeatedly and very
aggressively as a foreign agent last
night she hit back New York Times and
CNN have also smeared veterans like
myself for calling for an end to this
regime change war just two days ago the
New York Times put out a an article
saying that I'm a Russian asset and an
Assad apologist and all these different
smears this morning a CNN commentator
said on national television that I'm an
asset of Russia completely despicable
yeah and CNN doesn't care for her either
we know that for a fact because recent
footage from Project Veritas shows a
scene an employee conceding that the
network is institutionally hostile tell
C Garrett of Hawaii joins us so
congresswoman you just heard that I
don't know if you've seen that any but
on the road but there's just seen an
employee saying that for taking an
unconventional foreign policy position
you are the one Democratic candidate
that Cena doesn't like does that
surprise you it doesn't you know I think
it's kind of absurd actually that as we
saw in in the days leading up to the
debate last night both the New York
Times and CNN both ran hit pieces today
the day after the debate we see more of
these hit pieces coming coming out and
for them to to sit there and try to
portray themselves as neutral arbiters
as objective and independent and to
he's working with the DNC to carry out a
legitimate debate as is frankly it's
just a joke
she looks reasons why I've been calling
for you know a nonprofit organization
like the League of Women Voters right to
actually host these debates in a way
that actually serves the interests of
voters not the profit you know the
profit bearing corporate interests of
the corporate media I couldn't agree
more
sue so just for our viewers who maybe
haven't followed this the when we say
you've been attacked by the New York
Times and CNN it's not attacked like
they're saying your health care plans
too expensive they're saying that you're
working for a foreign power against
America's interest that you're a traitor
to our country that New York Times piece
essentially said that what is this about
well this is exactly what happens to
those like myself who are trying to end
this regime change war in Syria who are
calling for an end to our country's
policy of being the world's police bring
about an end to these regime change wars
and this is something that is not just
happening to me you know when they're
issuing these smear attacks really what
they're doing is smearing anyone who's
calling for an end to these regime
change wars including veterans who I
meet almost every single day all across
this country who are not pacifists but
who understand and know firsthand the
cost of war and who are strongly
strongly calling for our country to put
an end to these counterproductive regime
change wars so when they are issuing
these smears and calling me a traitor to
my country they're essentially issuing
these smears and attacks to every
veteran who has has been willing to lay
their lives down in service to our
country you know there there are many
things we don't agree about one of the
reasons I'm so sympathetic to you and
what you're doing is because I've been
there I know exactly what you're saying
and what you're saying is absolutely
real it's the one subject that they
won't accept any deviation on and so you
deserve credit I think for your bravery
in going forward thank you tulsi gabbard
great to see you tonight
thanks sucker